hurricane irma is expected to make a
sharp turn toward florida over the
weekend hurricane wilma was the last big
storm to hit florida head on back in
2005. that category 3 hurricane killed
23 people it caused around 20 billion
dollars in damage in the u.s
irma is threatening all of the state
including the low-lying florida keys
those islands could be swamped by a
catastrophic storm surge manuel bohorkis
is in key largo where thousands of
people will soon be leaving manuel good
morning
good morning a mandatory evacuation for
tourists here in the florida keys went
into effect just minutes ago an
evacuation order for residents will
start at seven tonight and complicating
matters here as you see that bridge
right there that is highway one and it's
the only way on or off the islands
for the florida keys if you were going
to create the worst case scenario
that's what we're now looking at as
hurricane irma sets its sights on south
florida officials in the keys are
sounding the alarm we're emphatically
telling people you must evacuate you
cannot afford to stay on an island with
a category five hurricane coming at you
many people are listening
boarding up their homes and businesses
filling up their gas tanks
and getting out of town do not sit and
wait to prepare get prepared now florida
governor rick scott also issued several
urgent warnings tuesday storm surge and
extreme winds are the biggest concern
right now storm surge is especially a
concern in the keys which are on average
about six feet above sea level the
search during hurricane irma has
potential to be more than nine feet high
we could be looking at
wave heights that would literally put
the ocean over the islands elizabeth
prieto lives in the keys and is
evacuating for the first time in 51
years i've been through george been
through andrew been through wilma but
i'm not staying for irma
not happening
key west international airport will
close tonight so all commercial flights
have been canceled until further notice
so anyone who will decide to ride out
the storm here in the keys well
officials are saying you're going to be
on your own because no storm shelters
will be open anywhere in monroe county
gail that means don't mess with that
thank you very much manuel